(lively music)
- [Voiceover] I tell
everyone I got laid off
from a job because of pay cuts,
but I got fired because
I stole people's food
from the fridge.
No regrets.
- [Voiceover] I got fired from Starbucks
for drawing a dick on a
girl's caramel macchiato.
She called corporate.
- [Voiceover] I'm gonna call corporate.
- [Voiceover] Today I
got fired for making out
with my boyfriend when he stopped by work.
Whoops.
(crowd chatters angrily)
- [Voiceover] I got fired
because because of a work selfie.
Whatever.
- [Voiceover] I got fired
for always calling in sick
just so I could stay home and play Skyrim.
I still have no regrets.
- [Voiceover] One time I got sick at work
and drank what I thought was DayQuil,
but it ended up being NyQuil,
and I got fired for
being drunk on the job.
(drunken mumbling)
- [Voiceover] I got
fired from my first job
because I would get high
and taste the fries.
Like you wouldn't.
- [Voiceover] I was
fired because I had sex
in my office after hours.
My manager?
Yeah, he was upset to say the least.
- [Voiceover] I was fired
because I couldn't staple papers
to my boss's satisfaction.
What is that?
- [Voiceover] I used to
dress up as Prince Eric
at Disneyland parades for five years
until I got fired for
doing porn on the side.
Still don't see what the big deal was.
(lively music)